It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的生意规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐吧。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. It's December, which means it's peak season for charitable giving. If you're planning to donate money to charity this year, here's a question for you. How do you decide which organizations to support? How do you weigh the relative worthiness of, say, a children's arts program, a local food bank, or an anti-malarial campaign on another continent? Do you focus on causes that are personally meaningful to you?
Google Fi Wireless 在网络使用高峰期不会受到数据流量降速的影响。现在是十二月，这意味着这是慈善捐赠的高峰期。如果您今年计划向慈善机构捐款，这里有一个问题要问您。您是如何决定支持哪些组织的？您如何权衡不同项目的相对价值，比如儿童艺术项目、当地食品银行，或者在另一个大洲开展的抗疟疾运动？您是专注于对您个人有意义的事业吗？
Or do you try to donate to organizations that spend their money most effective? For psychologists who study moral thinking, questions like this offer a tangible illustration of how people make moral choices. Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who studies moral thinking and has turned his research into a platform that he hopes will encourage people to donate more effectively. So what is moral psychology? When people are making moral decisions, do they lean on their emotions, their rational thinking, or both?
还是您会尝试向那些最有效地使用资金的组织捐款？对于研究道德思维的心理学家来说，这样的问题提供了一个具体的例证，说明人们是如何做出道德选择的。今天，我们将与一位研究道德思维的心理学家交谈，他已将自己的研究转化为一个平台，希望以此鼓励人们更有效地捐款。那么，什么是道德心理学？当人们做出道德决定时，他们是依赖自己的情感、理性思维，还是两者兼而有之？
happening in the brain when people consider moral choices? And what implications does this have for practical questions from where people donate money to how people and groups cooperate in a polarized world? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Joshua Green, a professor of psychology at Harvard University, where he uses behavioral and neuroscience methods to study how people make moral judgments. He's also the co-founder of Giving Multiplier, a research-based donation platform that aims to increase the impact of charitable giving. Dr. Green is author of the book Moral Tribes, Emotion,
当人们考虑道德选择时，大脑中发生了什么？这对从人们捐款去向到人们和群体如何在两极分化的世界中合作等实际问题有什么影响？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是哈佛大学心理学教授约书亚·格林博士，他利用行为学和神经科学方法研究人们如何做出道德判断。他还是基于研究的捐赠平台“捐赠倍增器”（Giving Multiplier）的联合创始人，该平台旨在提高慈善捐赠的影响力。格林博士著有《道德部落：情感、
Reason, and The Gap Between Us and Them. He's published dozens of peer-reviewed journal articles, and his work has been covered by media outlets, including NPR, The Atlantic, and The Washington Post. Dr. Green, thank you for joining me today. Thank you. Delighted to be here. I introduced this episode by talking about charitable giving, and we're going to talk about that, but I want to start with something else that our listeners may have heard of. And that's the trolley problem.
理性，以及我们与他们之间的鸿沟》一书。他发表了数十篇同行评审的期刊文章，他的工作被包括美国国家公共电台（NPR）、《大西洋月刊》和《华盛顿邮报》在内的媒体报道。格林博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。我在介绍本期节目时谈到了慈善捐赠，我们将讨论这个话题，但我先想从我们的听众可能听说过的另一个话题开始。那就是电车难题。
For those who don't know, could you explain what is the trolley problem and what can it tell us about how people make moral decisions? Well, so the trolley problem has been a kind of obsession of mine since I was an undergrad, and I'm now in my 50s to give you an idea of how long this has been. And I introduced this into research in moral psychology and the then burgeoning field of cognitive neuroscience of morality now over 20 years ago. The gist of it is that these moral dilemmas
对于那些不知道的人，您能解释一下什么是电车难题，以及它能告诉我们关于人们如何做出道德决定的什么信息吗？嗯，电车难题从我本科起就一直是我的一种执念，我现在已经 50 多岁了，这让你知道这已经持续多久了。我在 20 多年前就将其引入了道德心理学和当时正在兴起的道德认知神经科学领域。它的要点是，这些道德困境
are nice little fruit flies for understanding dissociable and sometimes competing mechanisms in our brains when we're making moral decisions. So the two sort of classic, versions of the trolley problem, which will be familiar to many of your listeners, but not everybody, go like this. So in one version, which we'll call the switch case, the trolley is headed towards five people, and you can save those five people, but you have to hit a switch that will turn the trolley onto a different track, where in the canonical case, it will run over one person
就像是理解我们在做出道德决定时大脑中可分离且有时相互竞争的机制的绝佳小果蝇。所以，电车难题的两个经典版本，许多听众可能很熟悉，但并非所有人，是这样的。在一个版本中，我们称之为“扳道岔案例”，电车正驶向五个人，你可以救那五个人，但你必须按下开关，将电车转向另一条轨道，在经典案例中，它会碾过一个人
instead. Now, this is the version that's gotten super memeified. So a lot of this is often been used as a kind of platform for just, what do you like more, or what do you hate more? Who or what Would you rather run over with the trolley? And, you know, I appreciate the memes, but from a psychology standpoint, the really interesting thing here is the contrast between that classic switch case and what I call the footbridge case. So in the footbridge case, the trolley is again headed towards five people. And the only way you can save them is to block the trolley. So you're on a footbridge over the tracks in between the oncoming trolley and the five people.
作为代替。现在，这个版本已经被极度模因化了。所以，这通常被用作一种平台，仅仅是为了问，你更喜欢什么，或者你更讨厌什么？你宁愿用电车碾过谁或什么？而且，你知道，我很欣赏这些模因，但从心理学角度来看，这里真正有趣的是那个经典的扳道岔案例与我所说的“人行天桥案例”之间的对比。在人行天桥案例中，电车再次驶向五个人。而你救他们的唯一方法就是阻挡电车。所以你站在轨道上方的人行天桥上，位于迎面而来的电车和那五个人之间，
and the only way you can save them is to push this other person, let's say it's a person with a very big backpack, onto the tracks, and you can use them as a trolley stopper, and that will kill that person, unfortunately, but it will save the five people, and no, you can't jump yourself because you are not wearing a big backpack and not able to stop it. And yes, we're going to assume that this will actually work.
而救他们的唯一方法就是把另一个人，比如说是一个背着大背包的人，推到轨道上，你可以把他们当作电车阻挡器，这不幸会杀死那个人，但会救下那五个人，而且不，你不能自己跳下去，因为你没有背大背包，无法阻止它。是的，我们假设这真的会奏效。
You've been to the movies, you know how to suspend disbelief. Even with all of those assumptions realistic or unrealistic, most people say, yeah, it's okay, to hit the switch in the first case, turn the trolley away from the five and on to the one. But they either say it's wrong or they feel much more uneasy about using somebody as a trolley stopper in that way,
你看过电影，你知道如何暂停怀疑。即使有所有这些现实或不现实的假设，大多数人还是会说，是的，在第一种情况下按下开关，让电车避开那五个人而转向那一个人是可以的。但他们要么说这是错误的，要么在以那种方式使用某人作为电车阻挡器时感到更加不安，
pushing somebody off of the footbridge to save five. And now after 25 years, we know a lot about what's going on in these different cases. And we could spend two hours just talking about all the evidence here. But the key thing is that there's a kind of emotional response that you get to pushing the person off of the footbridge, that you don't get to hitting that switch. What does it?
把某人从人行天桥上推下去以救五个人。现在 25 年过去了，我们对这些不同案例中发生的事情了解了很多。我们可以花两个小时专门讨论这里所有的证据。但关键在于，当你把人从人行天桥上推下去时，你会产生一种情感反应，而按下那个开关时则不会。这是为什么？
Again, this could be a whole episode, but it has to do with the fact that in that case, the harm is not only active, but it is intentional in the sense that you're using the person as a means to your end and that it's more direct. You're pushing with your muscles as opposed to hitting a switch.
同样，这可能需要一整集节目，但这与以下事实有关：在这种情况下，伤害不仅是主动的，而且是有意的，因为你把那个人当作实现你目的的手段，而且它更直接。你用肌肉去推，而不是按下开关。
All those things matter. And then when we look inside the head and even look neuroscientifically, what we see is a stronger emotional response. And we see this in a part of the brain called the amygdala, which you may recognize as, you know, what's going to light up if you show somebody
所有这些都很重要。然后当我们观察大脑内部，甚至从神经科学角度观察时，我们看到的是更强烈的情感反应。我们在大脑中一个叫做杏仁核的部分看到了这一点，你可能认出它，你知道，如果你给某人看
an angry face or a snake, it's a feeling of sort of there's a threat or there's something I need to orient to, something dangerous that requires my attention. And then that feeds signals to the ventromedial prefrontal cortex, which is the classic Phineas gauge region. This is the part of the brain that was damaged
一张愤怒的脸或一条蛇，它就会亮起来，这是一种威胁感，或者是我需要定位的东西，某种危险的东西，需要我的注意。然后它会将信号发送到腹内侧前额叶皮层，这是经典的菲尼亚斯·盖奇区域。这是大脑中受损的部分，
in that classic psych one case where damage to that part of the brain leaves people able to think kind of in a cold, rational way, but not in a way that's guided by intuition and emotion and instinct. Yeah. That was the guy who got the spike in his head. Exactly. Right. And yeah, so it does a couple hours north of where I am in Cambridge, Massachusetts. And, you know, the interesting thing about the footbridge case, yes, it's artificial. It's kind of like a visual illusion where, you know, you can look at those weird flashing checkerboards and it doesn't look like things you normally see,
在那个经典的心理学案例中，大脑该部分的损伤使人们能够以一种冷酷、理性的方式思考，但不能以直觉、情感和本能引导的方式思考。是的。那就是那个头部被铁棍穿过的家伙。完全正确。而且，是的，它发生在我所在的马萨诸塞州剑桥市以北几个小时路程的地方。而且，你知道，关于人行天桥案例有趣的一点是，是的，它是人为的。它有点像视觉错觉，你知道，你可以看那些奇怪的闪烁棋盘，它看起来不像你平时看到的东西，
but it's a good way to drive the brain in a way that reveals the competing mechanics in the case of visual illusions of different visual processes. And the Footbridge case, in a sense, I think of it as, this is controversial, but I think of it as a kind of moral illusion. That is, it has the superficial features of a prototypically immoral act and in some ways deeper features.
但它是一种以揭示竞争机制的方式驱动大脑的好方法，在视觉错觉的情况下是不同的视觉过程。而人行天桥案例，在某种意义上，我认为它是——这很有争议，但我认为它是一种道德错觉。也就是说，它具有原型不道德行为的表面特征，在某些方面还有更深层的特征。
That is, you are harming somebody in a direct, active, intentional, violent way. It's like punching somebody in the face. But, and the weird twist is that this is a case whereby stipulation, you're serving the greater good by doing this. And that's what makes it this sort of strange kind of thing. And this case highlights the tension between emotion and reason in moral decision making,
也就是说，你正在以一种直接、主动、故意、暴力的方式伤害某人。这就像打某人的脸。但是，奇怪的转折是，这是一个通过约定，你通过这样做来服务于更大利益的案例。这就是让它成为这种奇怪事物的原因。这个案例突出了道德决策中情感与理性之间的张力，
loosely defined. There's emotion on both sides. There's reason on both sides, but as a first pass. And to sort of foreshadow our discussion today, you know, this is a dilemma that you could debate what's the right answer, but for most people, there's no comfortable solution. You can say, well, better to save five lives, well, you're left with that sense of, but isn't it horribly wrong to use somebody as a trolley stopper? Or you can say, no, it's wrong to use somebody as a trolley stopper. but then you have to deal with the fact that more people are coming out dead than necessary from that choice. In charitable giving, there is a similar dilemma, and that's the main topic of the research that I think we're going to talk mostly about today. But the good news is there is a middle way in the charitable dilemma in a way that there isn't for the footbridge case.
定义比较宽泛。双方都有情感。双方都有理性，但作为初步尝试。为了预示我们今天的讨论，你知道，这是一个你可以争论什么是正确答案的困境，但对大多数人来说，没有舒适的解决方案。你可以说，嗯，救五条命更好，好吧，你留下了那种感觉，但把某人当作电车阻挡器不是极其错误的吗？或者你可以说，不，把某人当作电车阻挡器是错误的，但随后你必须面对这样一个事实，即从那个选择中死的人比必要的要多。在慈善捐赠中，有一个类似的困境，这就是我认为我们今天主要要讨论的研究主题。但好消息是，在慈善困境中有一种中间道路，而人行天桥案例则没有。
And we will get there, but I want to mention something else because I read an interview where you said something to the effect of only psychopaths and Buddhist monks, choose to push someone in front of the trolley. Right. So why is that? Because these two groups don't have a heck of a lot in common. Why would they come to a moral judgment that most other people have a difficult time making? Right. And of course, I should say as a good scientist, that that's a broad brush based on the
我们会谈到那一点，但我还想提另一件事，因为我读过一次采访，你说过类似只有精神病患者和佛教僧侣才会选择把某人推到电车前的话。对吧？那为什么呢？因为这两类人并没有太多共同点。为什么他们会得出大多数其他人难以做出的道德判断？对吧。当然，作为一名优秀的科学家，我应该说这是一个基于我们所拥有的
research that we have. But so it's a dual process story, right? It's a story where on the one side, you have automatic intuitive responses. This is like, you know, connemon thinking fast and slow with an emotional element on the intuition side. and you can end up giving the same answer for different reasons that correspond to those two processes. So what we think is going on in the case of the psychopaths, they don't have much of a feeling that makes them say, no, it's wrong to harm somebody in this direct, violent kind of way.
研究的广泛概括。但这确实是一个双重过程的故事，对吧？这是一个故事，一方面，你有自动的直觉反应。这就像，你知道，卡尼曼的《思考，快与慢》，直觉方面带有情感元素。你最终可能会因为对应这两个过程的不同原因而给出相同的答案。所以我们认为在精神病患者身上发生的事情是，他们没有太多的感觉让他们说，不，以这种直接、暴力的方式伤害某人是错误的。
So they just sort of say, I don't know, what sounds like a reasonable response in this conversation? It doesn't mean they really care about saving more lives, but at least that sounds like a rational thing to say. So that's what they're more likely to say. with the Buddhist monks, and this is actually this is an unpublished study done by a remarkable undergrad named Shin Shang, former undergrad.
所以他们只是说，我不知道，在这场对话中听起来像是一个合理的回答是什么？这并不意味着他们真的关心挽救更多的生命，但至少这听起来像是一件理性的事情。所以这就是他们更有可能说的话。对于佛教僧侣，这实际上是一项由一位名叫申尚（Shin Shang）的杰出本科生完成的未发表研究，前本科生。
She did this as her senior thesis who went to Tibet and tested 50 Buddhist monks like in Lhasa up in the mountains and 80% of them approved of pushing the guy off the footbridge. Now, we couldn't get this paper published because people always said, well, we want follows, we want more of this, no, like, sorry, she's not going back to Tibet.
她把这作为她的毕业论文，她去了西藏，测试了 50 名佛教僧侣，比如在拉萨山上的那些，80% 的人赞成把那个人从人行天桥上推下去。现在，我们无法发表这篇论文，因为人们总是说，嗯，我们需要后续，我们需要更多这样的研究，不，抱歉，她不会再回西藏了。
So now it's just podcast lore. But we have this really strong effect. So what's going on with that? Well, we don't have good psychometrics on them, and we didn't put them in brain scanners, but from what we understand of the psychology, is part of what you're getting from training in Buddhism is a kind of awareness of your emotional responses to things
所以现在它只是播客传说。但我们有这个非常强烈的效应。那么这到底是怎么回事呢？嗯，我们没有关于他们的良好心理测量数据，也没有把他们放进脑部扫描仪，但从我们对心理学的理解来看，你从佛教训练中获得的部分东西是对你对事物的各种情感反应的一种觉知，
and a kind of detachment from them. That is to say, not that you don't feel it, but you see it for what it is, and you have a sort of choice. And you can imagine, in clinical context, this is incredibly useful that a lot of people who have training in meditation and Buddhist philosophy
以及一种对它们的超脱。也就是说，不是说你没有感觉到，而是你看到了它的本质，并且你有一种选择。你可以想象，在临床环境中，这是非常有用的，许多受过冥想和佛教哲学训练的人
go into clinical psychology because it's so useful. That is so much of what people are looking to deal with when they have clinical issues is feelings that they don't want to have and that are making them behave in ways that are either destructive or just the feelings themselves. So being able to step back from your fear or from your anger or whatever it is and then make a kind of rational choice,
进入临床心理学，因为它太有用了。人们在有临床问题时寻求处理的很大一部分是他们不想有、并且导致他们以破坏性方式行事或者仅仅是感觉本身的感觉。所以能够从你的恐惧或愤怒或任何东西中退后一步，然后做出一种理性的选择，
that's a very useful thing. And in the Buddhist tradition, in particular the Tibetan tradition, you are trained to be very aware of what you're feeling and to be able to decide, say, okay, do I want to trust with that feeling and go with it? Or do I want to go with something else? Now, if you ask the Buddhist, why did you make that choice? In this relatively small sample,
那是一件非常有用的事情。在佛教传统中，特别是藏传传统中，你被训练要非常清楚自己的感受，并能够决定，说，好吧，我想信任那种感觉并随它而去吗？还是我想选择其他东西？现在，如果你问佛教徒，你为什么做出那个选择？在这个相对较小的样本中，
I think five of them referred to this specific sutra, this teaching, which tells the story of the case of this ship captain who was, you know, the captain of a large ship and there was a bad guy on board who was going to kill everybody. And the captain knew that if the crew found out about this person, they would kill him and that would be bad for them,
我想有五个人提到了这个特定的经文，这个教义，它讲述了那个船长的案例，他，你知道，是一艘大船的船长，船上有一个坏人要杀掉所有人。船长知道如果船员发现了这个人，他们会杀了他，这对他们来说是不好的，
comically speaking, but also didn't want the bad guy to do his bad stuff. So the ship captain decides to kill the bad guy. And with the understanding that this would be bad for him in the next life, but he was sort of taking it as a personal sacrifice. But because it was done,
从因果报应的角度来说，但也不想让坏人做他的坏事。所以船长决定杀了那个坏人。并理解到这对他下一世是不好的，但他有点把它当作一种个人牺牲。但因为它是这样做的，
not for personal gain or even for, you know, to protect one's own personal interests like one's friends or family, but purely for the greater good. The result was actually, this was considered a noble act and the captain goes on to become a bodhisattva, an enlightened one who's engaged with the world.
不是为了个人利益，甚至不是为了，你知道，保护自己的个人利益，比如朋友或家人，而是纯粹为了更大利益。结果实际上是，这被认为是一种高尚的行为，船长后来成为了一名菩萨，一个参与世界的觉悟者。
So the Buddhists might not put it in sort of, what you might call utilitarian terms. They would focus more on the intention. That is that the intention was to promote the greater good, But you can think of it at the very least as a kind of utilitarian concern detached from the emotional response that might push you in the other direction. So I think what's going on here to sort of come back to your question, why do you get the same answer from two populations that might seem to be moral opposites?
所以佛教徒可能不会用你所谓的功利主义术语来表达。他们会更关注意图。也就是说，意图是为了促进更大利益，但你至少可以把它看作是一种脱离了可能把你推向相反方向的情感反应的功利主义关怀。所以我认为这里发生的事情，回到你的问题，为什么你会从两个看起来可能是道德对立的人群中得到相同的答案？
It's because it's a difference on the two different components of the dual process story about the moral psychology. The psychopaths don't have the feeling that says, hey, don't push people off of footbridges. The Buddhist monks have that feeling, but they choose to put it aside in this context where there's a greater good at stake. All right.
这是因为双重过程故事中两个不同组成部分的差异。精神病患者没有那种说“嘿，不要把人从人行天桥上推下去”的感觉。佛教僧侣有那种感觉，但他们选择在有更大利益处于危险之中的情况下将其放在一边。好的。
Now, we're going to get back to the trolley question in a minute, but I'm going to move back to charitable giving, because as I mentioned earlier, you started a platform called Giving Multiplier that aims to get people to donate money more effectively. So tell our listeners, what does it mean to donate effectively? How does the platform work?
现在，我们一会儿会回到电车问题，但我会回到慈善捐赠，因为正如我之前提到的，你创办了一个名为“捐赠倍增器”（Giving Multiplier）的平台，旨在让人们更有效地捐款。那么告诉我们的听众，有效捐赠意味着什么？这个平台是如何运作的？
Okay, so this is actually a bit of background that comes from outside of psychology, but that's important here. A lot of people don't know that there is such enormous variation in how effective different charities are. So you might think that the difference in effectiveness in charities is something like the difference in human height. So someone who's really tall might be 50% taller than someone who's really not that tall, right? But in fact, the differences can be more like a hundred times or even a thousand times. If you measure these things using the kinds of measurements that health economists and health psychologists use to measure medical outcomes, like how many lives are you saving per dollar or how much are you improving people's quality of life for every dollar or $1,000 that you spend.
好的，这实际上是一点来自心理学之外的背景，但在这里很重要。很多人不知道不同慈善机构的有效性差异如此巨大。所以你可能认为慈善机构有效性的差异就像人类身高的差异。所以一个非常高的人可能比一个不太高的人高 50%，对吧？但事实上，差异可能更像是 100 倍甚至 1000 倍。如果你使用健康经济学家和健康心理学家用来衡量医疗结果的那种测量方法来衡量这些事情，比如你每美元挽救了多少生命，或者你每花费一美元或 1000 美元改善了多少人的生活质量。
So, for example, in the United States, if you were to help people who are blind, so let's say paying for training a seeing eye dog for a blind person in the United States. training and seeing eye dog it costs about $50,000. It's a long intensive process that requires skilled labor. By contrast, in other parts of the world, people go blind because of a disease called trachoma,
所以，例如，在美国，如果你要帮助盲人，比如支付在美国为盲人培训导盲犬的费用。培训导盲犬大约需要 5 万美元。这是一个漫长而密集的流程，需要熟练劳动力。相比之下，在世界其他地方，人们因为一种叫做沙眼的疾病而失明，
which is an infection in the eye. And there is a simple surgery that can cost less than $100 that can prevent people from going blind from trachoma. So you do the math on that. You can fund over 100, maybe close to 1,000 surgeries that prevent people from going blind
这是一种眼部感染。有一种简单的手术，费用不到 100 美元，可以防止人们因沙眼而失明。所以你算一下。你可以资助 100 多次，也许接近 1000 次防止人们失明的手术，
in the first place for the cost of training a seeing eye dog in the United States. Now, does that mean that we should disregard the needs of blind people in the U.S.? That is not what I am saying. But to completely ignore the fact that we can do a hundred times, a thousand times more good
而成本只是在美国培训一只导盲犬的费用。那么，这是否意味着我们应该忽视美国盲人的需求？我不是这个意思。但是完全忽视这样一个事实，即我们可以在美国以外的失明预防或缓解方面多做 100 倍、1000 倍的好事，
on the topic of blindness prevention or mitigation outside, we shouldn't ignore that either. And that's what I mean by the differences between giving effectively or not. In the domain of global health and poverty, where this is most prominent, we have things like distributing malaria nets,
我们也不应该忽视这一点。这就是我所说的有效捐赠与否之间的差异。在全球健康和贫困领域，这是最突出的，我们有分发疟疾蚊帐之类的事情，
where the cost of distributing a malaria net all in, this is an insecticidal net that prevents people that you sleep under and prevents people typically in sub-Saharan Africa from contracting malaria, usually children under five who end up dying of malaria. It costs about $5 to distribute a net. If you distribute 1,000 nets in sort of key areas, on average you're likely to save one person's life.
分发疟疾蚊帐的全部成本，这是一种杀虫蚊帐，人们睡觉时在下面，可以防止人们，通常是在撒哈拉以南非洲，感染疟疾，通常是五岁以下最终死于疟疾的儿童。分发一个蚊帐大约需要 5 美元。如果你在关键地区分发 1000 个蚊帐，平均来说，你很可能会挽救一个人的生命。
And that means you can save someone's life for something around $5,000. Now, that may be more expensive than a lot of people think, but it is a far more effective than, let's say, things that people often want to fund in affluent countries like cancer research, which is very expensive, and the life save for every $5,000 is nowhere close to that. And then there are other programs like deworming treatments that get rid of intestinal worms for less than a dollar, and then a charity will talk about at greater length, which will give directly, which makes direct cash transfers to people in living in extreme poverty.
这意味着你可以用大约 5000 美元挽救一个人的生命。现在，这可能比许多人想象的要贵，但它比人们通常想在富裕国家资助的事情要有效得多，比如癌症研究，这非常昂贵，每 5000 美元挽救的生命远不及这个数字。还有其他项目，比如驱虫治疗，不到一美元就能消除肠道寄生虫，还有一个慈善机构我们会更详细地讨论，即“直接给予”（Give Directly），它直接向生活在极端贫困中的人们进行现金转移。
And those programs make enormous difference in people's lives in a way that goes far beyond anything we can do helping people in a place like the United States or in Europe because just the money goes so much farther there. So that's one kind of effectiveness. Then there's also things that are related to, let's say, climate change. There are things you can do that don't do a lot of good. And then there are other kinds of technological and lobbying oriented things that have a track record of making an enormous difference. There is things in animal welfare. So, you know, supporting the local animal shelter can make a few animals, typically companion animals that humans feel very close to, have better lives.
这些项目在人们的生活中产生了巨大的差异，其方式远远超出了我们在美国或欧洲等地方帮助人们所能做的，因为那里的钱能走得更远。所以这是一种有效性。还有一些与，比如说，气候变化相关的事情。有些事情你可以做，但并没有多大好处。还有其他一些技术和游说导向的事情，有产生巨大差异的记录。在动物福利方面也有一些事情。所以，你知道，支持当地的动物收容所可以让一些动物，通常是人类感觉非常亲近的伴侣动物，过上更好的生活。
But if you support a charity like the Humane League, you can make a difference for thousands of animals that are living in terrible conditions in factory farms. So there are organizations like Give Well, which does an incredible job. They've like a team of something like 20 researchers working full time trying to figure out in the domain of health and poverty what saves the most likely. lives per dollar, what improves the quality of life the most per dollar. You have animal charity evaluators doing similar things for animal well-being. And then you have groups like Founders Pledge that look at things that are kind of more big bets like mitigating climate change and trying
但如果你支持像“人道联盟”（Humane League）这样的慈善机构，你可以为成千上万生活在工厂化农场恶劣条件下的动物带来改变。所以有像“给予良好”（Give Well）这样的组织，他们做得非常出色。他们有一个大约 20 名研究人员组成的团队全职工作，试图弄清楚在健康和贫困领域，什么每美元挽救的生命最多，什么每美元改善的生活质量最多。你有“动物慈善评估员”（Animal Charity Evaluators）为动物福利做类似的事情。然后你有像“创始人承诺”（Founders Pledge）这样的组织，他们关注一些更大的赌注，比如缓解气候变化，试图
to prevent the next pandemic and making calculations about what's most likely to produce the biggest impact. So all of that is research we're taking is given from organizations that have very smart and well-trained people doing their best to figure out what, What's the most good you can do with $1,000 or a dollar for that matter? And then the question is, okay, if we take their evidence-based recommendations as given, what about the human choice, right? It turns out that what people are most drawn to is typically not the stuff that's most effective. And I say this as one of these people.
防止下一次大流行，并计算什么最有可能产生最大的影响。所以所有这些都是我们从那些拥有非常聪明和训练有素的人员的组织那里得到的建议，他们尽最大努力弄清楚，用 1000 美元或一美元，你能做的最大的好事是什么？然后问题是，好的，如果我们接受他们基于证据的建议作为既定事实，那么人类的选择呢，对吧？事实证明，人们最被吸引的东西通常不是最有效的东西。我作为这些人之一这么说。
I mean, my wife and I, you know, we live here in Massachusetts, and we like to support the local public schools where our kids went to school, the Boston Food Bank, which is feeding people during a difficult time. We feel a very strong pull to support things in our community or that are personally meaningful to us. But we also know that there are these extraordinarily impactful charities. And as much as we love Cambridge Public Schools and the Boston Food Bank, we know that what they do does not have the kind of impact that these other organizations can have.
我的意思是，我和我妻子，你知道，我们住在马萨诸塞州，我们喜欢支持我们孩子上学的当地公立学校，波士顿食品银行，它在困难时期为人们提供食物。我们感到一种非常强烈的动力去支持我们社区的事物，或者对我们个人有意义的事物。但我们也知道有这些极其有影响力的慈善机构。尽管我们热爱剑桥公立学校和波士顿食品银行，但我们知道他们所做的事情并没有这些其他组织所能产生的那种影响。
And so what we do is we do both. And you might say from a certain point of view that's not optimal, why not give everything to the super effective stuff. But it fits with our human psychology, right? And so the insight behind giving multiplier, and this was researched done originally with Lucius Caviola, who I'm now delighted to say as a professor
所以我们做的是两者兼顾。你可能会从某种角度说那不是最优的，为什么不把所有东西都给超级有效的东西呢。但这符合我们的人类心理，对吧？所以“捐赠倍增器”背后的洞察力，这是最初与卢修斯·卡维奥拉（Lucius Caviola）一起做的研究，我现在很高兴地说他是一位教授
at Cambridge across the pond in the UK, looking at how people respond to a request to do both. That is, in those initial experiments, in the control condition, we gave people the usual choice, which is pick your favorite, charity and you can give, you know, we're giving you $10, you can direct it wherever you want, just give us the link to your favorite charity. Or here's a super effective charity that, you know,
在英国剑桥，跨越池塘，研究人们如何回应做两者的请求。也就是说，在那些最初的实验中，在对照组中，我们给了人们通常的选择，即选择你最喜欢的慈善机构，你可以捐赠，你知道，我们给你 10 美元，你可以把它引导到任何你想去的地方，只需给我们你最喜欢的慈善机构的链接。或者这是一个超级有效的慈善机构，你知道，
can deworm 100 children for $100. That's the control condition. And what we find found there is that most people, like 80% of people, will choose to support their favorite charity, even if they've heard what experts have to say about how unbelievably affected this other thing is. In the experimental condition, if you say, well, you can do those two things, or there's a third option, split the money 50-50 between your favorite charity when you get to pick and, let's say, this deworming charity, we found that a little over 50% of people in that first experiment chose to do the split and that more money ended up going to the super effective deworming charity if you offered people the split option than if you force people to choose.
可以用 100 美元为 100 名儿童驱虫。那是对照组。我们在那里发现的是，大多数人，比如 80% 的人，会选择支持他们最喜欢的慈善机构，即使他们听到了专家关于这个其他东西是多么不可思议地有效。在实验组中，如果你说，嗯，你可以做这两件事，或者有第三个选择，把钱 50-50 分给你可以选择的你最喜欢的慈善机构和，比如说，这个驱虫慈善机构，我们发现第一个实验中略多于 50% 的人选择了进行拆分，而且如果你给人们拆分选项，比你强迫人们选择，更多的钱最终流向了超级有效的驱虫慈善机构。
So there is something really powerful about giving people the option to do both. And then we did a lot of experiments to try to figure out psychologically what's going on here and how do we turn this into something we can use and happy to say more about that, but let me pause there. But just to give people a better idea of exactly what this is, there's a website you can go to, right, the giving multiplier, and you can make decisions there. So you plug in the charity you want to give to and then you get some options for other charities and you get a split. And then there's money put on top of that, right? Right. So I'll sort of briefly describe the research leading to this. So first we wanted to understand what's really going on here. And what we really found was that when people support the charity that's close to their hearts, it's not so much about how much you give, but just that you're giving something. If you give $50 or $100 to the cancer charity when your beloved diet of breast cancer and so you want to support that, the amount doesn't matter so much. That means if you have $100 to give, if you give $50 to that charity, you get that feeling of
所以给人们做两者的选择确实有一些非常强大的东西。然后我们做了很多实验来试图弄清楚心理上发生了什么，以及我们如何把它变成我们可以使用的东西，很高兴多说一点，但我先停在这里。但为了让人们更好地了解这到底是什么，有一个你可以去的网站，对吧，捐赠倍增器，你可以在那里做决定。所以你输入你想捐赠的慈善机构，然后你会得到其他慈善机构的一些选择，你会得到一个拆分。然后上面还有钱，对吧？对。所以我将简要描述导致这一点的研究。所以首先我们想了解这里到底发生了什么。我们真正发现的是，当人们支持他们心目中的慈善机构时，这与其说捐多少，不如说只是你捐了一些东西。如果你给癌症慈善机构 50 或 100 美元，当你的挚爱死于乳腺癌，所以你想支持那个，金额并不那么重要。这意味着如果你有 100 美元可以捐，如果你给那个慈善机构 50 美元，你就会得到那种感觉
satisfaction of supporting that charity that means a lot to you personally by giving the 50. And then you have another 50. And if you use that 50 in a way that an expert will tell you have a huge impact, now you feel like not only did you give from the heart, but you also gave in this way that's really smart, people really like that. And so then we thought, okay, well, we could publish a paper saying, hey, make split donations and then no one would do anything. So we'd say, well, what if we add money on top? And that's something we can promote. And we found that people really like it when you say not, if you do this split, we'll add money on top, people say, great, and that adds like another 70% of people who do the
通过捐赠 50 美元来支持对你个人意义重大的慈善机构的满足感。然后你还有另外 50 美元。如果你以专家会告诉你会有巨大影响的方式使用那 50 美元，现在你觉得不仅你从内心捐赠了，而且你还以这种非常聪明的方式捐赠了，人们真的很喜欢那样。所以我们想，好吧，我们可以发表一篇论文说，嘿，进行拆分捐赠，然后没有人会做任何事。所以我们会说，嗯，如果我们额外增加钱呢？这是我们可以推广的东西。我们发现人们真的很喜欢当你不仅说，如果你这样做拆分，我们会额外增加钱，人们说，太棒了，这增加了另外 70% 的人进行
split. But then the question is, well, where's that money going to come from? And then we thought, well, what if we asked people, maybe after the fact, would you support a matching fund to pay it forward for other people so that they can get this kind of bonus on top? Or can you direct the part that you were going to give to the super effective charity that you just learned about to that matching fund instead? And we found us enough people were willing to support the matching fund to cover the matching funds for the people who chose to just take the matching funds. And so we were like, wow, this could really work. So Lucius and his techie friends created a website called Giving Multiplier, which is now in its fifth year. I'll tell you how it works, and then I'll tell
拆分。但问题是，钱从哪里来？然后我们想，嗯，如果我们问人们，也许事后，你会支持一个匹配基金来为其他人预付，以便他们能在上面得到这种奖金吗？或者你可以把你本来要给超级有效慈善机构的那部分钱，你刚刚了解到的，转而给那个匹配基金吗？我们发现有足够多的人愿意支持匹配基金，以覆盖那些选择只拿匹配基金的人的匹配基金。所以我们当时想，哇，这真的行得通。所以卢修斯和他的技术朋友创建了一个名为“捐赠倍增器”的网站，现在已经是第五个年头了。我会告诉你它是如何运作的，然后我会告诉你
you about what we've, the results. So if you go to the website, what you'll see is, you know, a little description of how it works, you choose a personal favorite charity. So any charity is a little, you know, field that you can fill in where you put in any charity that's registered in the U.S. of 501c3. And then we have a list of 10, super effective charities covering different areas. A lot of them global health and poverty, but some of them animal welfare or climate, things like that. And then we have this cool little slider where you put in the total amount and then you decide how you want to allocate that between the one that you picked and the one that's on our list of super effective charities.
关于我们，结果。所以如果你去网站，你会看到，你知道，关于它是如何运作的一点描述，你选择一个个人最喜欢的慈善机构。所以任何慈善机构都是一个小，你知道，你可以填写的字段，你输入任何在美国注册的 501c3 慈善机构。然后我们有一个包含 10 个超级有效慈善机构的列表，涵盖不同领域。很多是全球健康和贫困，但有些是动物福利或气候，诸如此类的事情。然后我们有这个很酷的小滑块，你输入总金额，然后你决定如何在你选择的那个和我们在超级有效慈善机构列表上的那个之间分配它。
And the way we set it up, the more you give to the ones that are on our super effective list, the more money we add on top up to 50%. We do have a code for list. We do have a code for listeners, but I actually want to mention a different campaign because this year we're doing a campaign with a bunch of podcasts, including this podcast. And this is with one of the charities that we've recommended from the start. This is with give directly. I'll get to that in a sec, but I have to brag a little bit about how well-giving multiplier has worked. So we started this five years ago. We've raised over $5 million for charities in general, and close to $3 million of that has gone to our list of super effective charities.
我们设置它的方式是，你给我们在超级有效列表上的那些捐得越多，我们额外增加的钱就越多，最高可达 50%。我们确实有一个听众代码，但我实际上想提一个不同的活动，因为今年我们正在与一堆播客进行一项活动，包括这个播客。这是与我们从一开始就推荐的慈善机构之一合作的。这是与“直接给予”合作的。我一会儿会讲到，但我必须吹嘘一下“捐赠倍增器”运作得有多好。所以我们五年前开始了这项工作。我们已经为慈善机构筹集了超过 500 万美元，其中近 300 万美元流向了我们的超级有效慈善机构列表。
So this has been over 5,000 donors and over 2,600 people giving to their personal favorite charities. And based on Givewell's estimates just for the health and poverty charity, so like malaria nets and vaccines and things like that, we estimate that the money we've moved has saved about 220 people's lives. So this is a case where psychology can really make a difference
所以这已经超过了 5000 名捐赠者，超过 2600 人向他们个人最喜欢的慈善机构捐款。根据“给予良好”仅针对健康和贫困慈善机构的估计，比如疟疾蚊帐和疫苗之类的事情，我们估计我们转移的资金已经挽救了大约 220 人的生命。所以这是一个心理学确实可以产生差异的案例
if you get the psychology right. But this holiday season, we have our biggest campaign, We're super excited about this, and this is with podcast partners. And this is specifically with a charity called Give Directly, which I mentioned before. Give Directly takes a different approach. It's actually an interesting story how this was created. There were economists who were interested in trying to figure out what works best when it
如果你把心理学搞对了。但这个节日季，我们有我们最大的活动，我们对此感到非常兴奋，这是与播客合作伙伴合作的。这是专门与一个名为“直接给予”的慈善机构合作的，我之前提到过。“直接给予”采取了不同的方法。它实际上是一个有趣的故事，关于这是如何创建的。有一些经济学家对试图弄清楚什么最有效感兴趣，当
comes to charitable giving, and particularly sort of global health and poverty. And they wanted to have a baseline to compare interventions to, you know, what happens if you give people vaccines? What happens if you give people filters for clean water or whatever it is? And they said, well, what happens if you just take the money that you would spend and just give it directly to people? And what they found was that that control condition did incredibly well and often did a lot better than the things that they were looking to compare it against. And more recent evidence has shown that when you give people who are living in extreme poverty, just give them cash directly, it not only helps them and they're able to spend it on things like, food or medical care or repairing a broken roof or investing in themselves. So investing in education,
涉及到慈善捐赠时，特别是全球健康和贫困。他们想有一个基准来比较干预措施，你知道，如果你给人们疫苗会发生什么？如果你给人们清洁水的过滤器或任何东西会发生什么？他们说，嗯，如果你只是拿你会花的钱，直接给人们会发生什么？他们发现那个对照组做得非常好，而且通常比他们试图比较的东西做得好得多。最近的证据表明，当你给生活在极端贫困中的人们，只是直接给他们现金，它不仅帮助了他们，而且他们能够把它花在诸如食物或医疗护理或修理破损的屋顶或投资自己之类的事情上。所以投资于教育，
money that they might need to start a business. Like let's say you want to sell, you want to have a business where you sell things to different villages, but you need a way to get around. So you need a little moped and gas for it, right? That the money can be used not only to take care of immediate needs like food and medical care, but in long-term investments. And recent study have shown that for every dollar that goes in, there's a 2.5 times boost in the local economy, right? So there are things where the measurable and immediate impact may be higher than giving cash directly. But if you think that there's some value in donating in a way where people can choose for themselves, how to spend the money, that kind of agency, if that's important to you, this is a really great charity for that.
他们可能需要创业的钱。比如你想卖东西，你想有一个生意，你卖东西给不同的村庄，但你需要一种四处走动的方法。所以你需要一辆小摩托车和汽油，对吧？钱不仅可以用来照顾食物和医疗护理等迫切需求，还可以用于长期投资。最近的研究表明，每投入一美元，当地经济就会有 2.5 倍的增长，对吧？所以有些事情，可衡量的和直接的影响可能比直接给现金更高。但如果你认为以人们可以自己选择如何花钱的方式捐赠是有价值的，那种代理权，如果这对你很重要，这是一个非常好的慈善机构。
And if you're really thinking long term, the way you pull people out of poverty long term is through economic development, is by giving people the resources so that they can build the kind of society that sustains itself economically, that's a real argument for this. Now, economists go back and forth on what's better to do now with the dollar, but this is at least a strength of this.
如果你真的在考虑长期，你长期把人们拉出贫困的方法是通过经济发展，是通过给人们资源，以便他们能够建立那种在经济上自我维持的社会，这是一个真正的论点。现在，经济学家对现在用一美元做什么更好来回争论，但这至少是它的一个优势。
So we love Give Directly, and we originally did a promotion with them with our dear friend Lori Santos, who's also a psychologist and hosts the amazing Happiness Lab podcast, and she and her podcasting friends decided to go big on GiveDirectly this year. So we are doing a pods fight poverty campaign
所以我们喜欢“直接给予”，我们最初与我们亲爱的朋友洛里·桑托斯（Lori Santos）一起为他们做了一次推广，她也是一位心理学家，主持了很棒的“幸福实验室”（Happiness Lab）播客，她和她的播客朋友决定今年在“直接给予”上大干一场。所以我们正在进行一场“播客对抗贫困”（pods fight poverty）活动。
with I think over 20, maybe 30 podcasts, including this one. We're looking to raise a million dollars for GiveDirectly with the goal of supporting three villages in Rwanda, over 700 families, no strings attached, cash transfers, and this could be transformative for the people who live in these villages. And the link for that is give directly.org, That's all one word.
我想大概有20，也许30个播客，包括这一个。我们正寻求为“直接给予”（GiveDirectly）筹集一百万美元，目标是支持卢旺达的三个村庄，超过700个家庭，提供无附加条件的现金转账，这对这些村庄的居民来说可能是变革性的。相关链接是givedirectly.org，全部连在一起。
For this podcast, it's slash speak. If you decide to support that, then you'll be logged as a speaking of psychology listener. And then giving multipliers role in this is that we're supplying the batching funds. So while our supplies last, our funds last, we're adding 50% on top of any donations you make as a speaking of psychology listener. So that's give directly.org slash speak. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Green about what happens when AI systems make moral decisions and whether moral psychology can help guide us as we build this new technology.
对于这个播客，网址是斜杠speak。如果您决定支持，您将被记录为“心理学谈话”（Speaking of Psychology）的听众。而“给予乘数”（Giving Multipliers）的作用在于我们提供配捐资金。因此，在我们的供应和资金用完之前，对于您作为“心理学谈话”听众所做的任何捐款，我们都会额外增加50%。所以网址是givedirectly.org/speak。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与格林博士探讨当人工智能系统做出道德决策时会发生什么，以及在我们构建这项新技术时，道德心理学能否提供指导。
Make every get-together chill. This Memorial Day, get up to an extra $1,000 off select top brand appliances like LG. Plus, get free delivery at the Home Depot. Tackle pool towels and camp laundry with a large capacity washer. And host and style with the fridge serving craft ice, mini craft ice, cube dice, and crushed ice. Shop appliance savings now through June 3rd at the Home Depot. Offer valid May 14th through June 3rd, US only. Free delivery on appliance purchases of $998 or more.
让每一次聚会都轻松惬意。这个阵亡将士纪念日，购买LG等精选顶级品牌家电，最高可额外优惠1000美元。此外，在家得宝（The Home Depot）还可享受免费送货服务。用大容量洗衣机轻松搞定泳池毛巾和露营衣物。用配备精酿冰块、迷你精酿冰块、方块冰和碎冰功能的冰箱来招待宾客，尽显格调。即日起至6月3日，在家得宝选购家电，享受优惠。优惠有效期为5月14日至6月3日，仅限美国。购买998美元及以上家电可享免费送货。
The C store online for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
详情请查看C商店在线页面。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路在哪里。我们省了多少钱？够了。够去迷路了！或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for this day. Now, I'm going to change gears yet again. I want to talk about artificial intelligence. And people often bring up the trolley problem in discussions of self-driving cars. And I'm curious to get your take on that. So what happens when AI systems have to make moral decisions? Can moral psychology help guide us as we're building this technology? Yeah, I think it can.
希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在Hilton.com或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享8折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要的是实惠，而不是惊喜时，住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为你而住。现在，我要再次转换话题。我想谈谈人工智能。人们在讨论自动驾驶汽车时经常提到“电车难题”。我很想听听你的看法。那么，当人工智能系统必须做出道德决策时会发生什么？在我们构建这项技术时，道德心理学能提供帮助吗？是的，我认为可以。
And part of the debate in this field is whether or not the trolley problem is a kind of good guide is useful for thinking about this. And the debate kind of goes like this. So, you know, the original trolley case is one where, for purpose of simplicity, all the outcomes are known, and they follow deterministically from whatever choice you make. So either you kill one person
这个领域争论的一部分是，“电车难题”是否是一个好的指导，或者说它是否有用。争论大致是这样的：你知道，最初的电车案例是为了简单起见，所有的结果都是已知的，并且它们会根据你所做的任何选择确定性地发生。所以要么你杀死一个人
and save five people, or you allow five people to die, but you save the one person. And, you know, the people who are designing self-driving car technology point out, I think fairly is, rarely, if ever, do you have a situation where you have this stark choice like that.
拯救五个人，要么你让五个人死去，但你拯救了那一个人。而且，你知道，那些设计自动驾驶汽车技术的人指出，我认为很公平的一点是，你几乎很少会遇到这种极其严峻的选择。
And the main thing that we want from self-driving cars is to avoid collisions in tire. right, that there are 40,000 road fatalities, and we want to just get to the point where whatever a self-driving car might do in an extremely rare trolley-type situation, the main thing is to have machines doing a better job
我们对自动驾驶汽车的主要要求是避免碰撞，对吧？道路上有4万起死亡事故，我们只是想达到这样一个目标：无论自动驾驶汽车在极罕见的电车式情况下可能会做什么，最重要的是让机器做得比人类驾驶员更好，
than human drivers so that fewer people die or get injured in road fatalities. So on the side of the software engineers and against some AI trolley enthusiasts, I do agree that the most important thing morally at stake here is to reduce road fatalities and injuries. And once the self-driving technology gets to the point where it does that better,
从而减少道路死亡或受伤人数。因此，站在软件工程师一边，反对一些人工智能电车爱好者，我确实同意这里最重要的道德利害关系是减少道路死亡和伤害。一旦自动驾驶技术发展到比人类做得更好的地步，
then it really, I think, is a moral wrong to allow humans to continue to, through inattention and bad decision-making, cause people's deaths. We're not there yet. But that's the big prize. With that said, I don't think the trolley stuff is completely irrelevant,
那么我认为，允许人类继续因注意力不集中和糟糕的决策而导致他人死亡，确实是一种道德错误。我们还没到那一步。但那是最终的大奖。话虽如此，我不认为电车难题完全无关紧要，
but the way it plays out is more statistical. It's more in terms of apportioning risk rather than do you do this or do that. So let me give you an example. So you probably have the experience of you're driving in your car, and let's say there's a cyclist in front of you, driving in the road, right?
但它的表现方式更多是统计学上的。它更多是在分配风险，而不是“你做这个还是做那个”。让我给你举个例子。你可能有过这样的经历：你正在开车，假设前面有一名骑自行车的人在路上行驶，对吧？
It's a two-lane road, and you have to decide whether or not do I go around the cyclist. But there's oncoming traffic, right? Now, if you choose to go around the cyclist, maybe you're making a really risky judgment there. You're going to just barely miss the cyclist because you have to go fast
这是一条双车道公路，你必须决定是否要绕过骑车人。但有迎面而来的车辆，对吧？现在，如果你选择绕过骑车人，也许你是在做一个非常冒险的判断。你可能会险些撞到骑车人，因为你必须开得很快，
in order to get around and in front before that truck is too close to you, right? there's a question there about how much risk are you imposing on the cyclist? There's risk to yourself. There's risk to the person driving the truck, right? And there's sort of three different levels. Let's say the person in the truck's going to be fine because they're going to bowl you over if they hit you.
以便在卡车离你太近之前绕到它前面，对吧？这里有一个问题：你给骑车人施加了多少风险？你自己也有风险。开卡车的人也有风险，对吧？这里有三种不同的层面。假设卡车里的人会没事，因为如果他们撞到你，他们会把你撞翻。
You might be in a fair amount of trouble, you know, but the cyclist is really in trouble if there's a collision, right? We all know that some people drive nicely and responsibly, and some people drive like jerks. And some people take risks that are unacceptable, both risks to themselves and to other people. There's no way for AI to avoid those questions. Essentially, does the AI drive like a good, responsible, careful driver, does it drive like a jerk? Right. So there has to be a moral component that's going into this, right? If you barely miss a cyclist, is that a win or a loss? When you might say,
你可能会陷入相当大的麻烦，你知道，但如果发生碰撞，骑车人真的会有大麻烦，对吧？我们都知道有些人开车既礼貌又负责，而有些人开车像混蛋。有些人承担着不可接受的风险，既是对自己，也是对他人。人工智能无法回避这些问题。本质上，人工智能是像一个好的、负责任的、谨慎的司机那样开车，还是像个混蛋那样开车？对吧。所以这里必须有一个道德成分，对吧？如果你险些撞到骑车人，那是赢还是输？你可能会说，
well, reinforce that, you managed to pull ahead in traffic and you didn't hurt anybody. Great. Right. And if you're training a machine, you might say, okay, that was a positive example. Or you might say, no, that was terrible. You put that cyclist at risk. You were two inches away, right? When you went by, that's bad, right? Downgrade that. You give negative reinforcement for the algorithm that produced that outcome. So when it comes to the level of training these things, choices have to be made about what counts as a good outcome or counts as a bad outcome. Where I see sort of trolleyology is useful here is it provides a kind of framework for thinking about what kinds of cost-benefit calculations are we willing to make? What kind of constraints do we want to impose?
嗯，加强这一点，你成功地在车流中超车，而且没有伤害任何人。太棒了。对吧。如果你在训练一台机器，你可能会说，好吧，那是一个积极的例子。或者你可能会说，不，那太糟糕了。你让那个骑车人处于危险之中。你经过时只有两英寸的距离，对吧？那很糟糕，对吧？降低那个评价。你给产生该结果的算法负面强化。所以当涉及到训练这些东西的层面时，必须做出选择，什么算作好的结果，什么算作坏的结果。我认为“电车学”在这里有用的地方在于，它提供了一种框架，用来思考我们愿意进行什么样的成本效益计算？我们想要施加什么样的约束？
And how do we sort of navigate higher-level trade-offs between a kind of hard constraint? Like, you must never ever get within 10 inches of a cyclist or a pedestrian or something like that, versus thinking about probabilities in terms of, are you likely to get to your destination on time, or are you likely to harm some other person or something like that? So some version of this moral psychology is going to have to be in the machine. Some aspects of it are going to be kind of trained in a black box sort of way, and some can be programmed as hard constraints. And I am not in this self-driving car business, but from what I understand, people are looking towards moral psychology and sort of the psychology of human decision-making more generally to think
以及我们如何处理某种硬性约束之间的高层权衡？比如，你绝对不能靠近骑车人或行人10英寸以内，等等，而不是考虑概率，比如，你是否可能准时到达目的地，或者你是否可能伤害其他人，等等？所以这种道德心理学的某种版本将不得不存在于机器中。它的一些方面将以黑箱的方式进行训练，而一些方面可以被编程为硬性约束。我不在自动驾驶汽车行业，但据我所知，人们正在寻求道德心理学和更广泛的人类决策心理学来思考
about what is the morally best way to train and constrain these driving systems. So some of your most recent work has focused on getting people to cooperate across political and other divides. Can you tell us about that work and how it relates to your work on moral thinking? Yeah. So, you know, my interest in trolley stuff was really always about the larger sort of philosophical problem and really about the rural world. So I came into psychology as a philosopher. My undergrad degree, my PhD are actually both in philosophy. And I was interested in these trolley problems because they pose a challenge for moral theory. I'm a consequentialist. I don't love the word utilitarian because I think it conjures up the wrong idea. I prefer to call myself a deep pragmatist, which is what I think I really am.
什么是训练和约束这些驾驶系统的道德上最好的方式。所以你最近的一些工作集中在让人们跨越政治和其他分歧进行合作。你能告诉我们关于这项工作以及它与你关于道德思维的工作有何联系吗？是的。所以，你知道，我对电车难题的兴趣一直在于更大的哲学问题，以及真正的现实世界。所以我作为一名哲学家进入了心理学领域。我的本科学位和博士学位实际上都是哲学。我对这些电车难题感兴趣，因为它们对道德理论提出了挑战。我是一个后果论者。我不喜欢“功利主义者”这个词，因为我认为它会引起错误的联想。我更喜欢称自己为深度实用主义者，这才是我想法中真正的样子。
And the goal of sort of studying the moral dilemmas and the psychology is partly just as interesting basic science. And now who knew, you know, it would have applications and things like self-driving cars. but part of it for me was always about the broader philosophical thinking about what's right and wrong and why and how should we organize our societies. Ten years ago or so, I published a book called Moral Tribes, which I have put my sort of philosophical thinking and my and other people's psychological and neuroscientific research altogether to try to answer the question of what should our philosophy be. And, you know, I'm proud of that book, but I also felt like it was a little unsatisfying to me. That is, I felt like you look at a book called Moral Tribes, Emotion, Reason, and, you know, I'm proud of that. and the gap between us and them. And you want a book that's going to tell you,
研究道德困境和心理学的目标，部分仅仅是因为它是基础科学，很有趣。现在谁知道呢，它竟然会在自动驾驶汽车等领域有应用。但对我来说，它的一部分一直在于关于什么是对什么是错、为什么以及我们应该如何组织我们的社会等更广泛的哲学思考。大约十年前，我出版了一本书叫《道德部落》（Moral Tribes），我把我自己的哲学思考以及其他人的心理学和神经科学研究放在一起，试图回答我们的哲学应该是什么的问题。而且，你知道，我为那本书感到自豪，但我也觉得它对我来说有点不尽如人意。也就是说，我觉得你看着一本叫《道德部落》的书，情感、理性，而且，你知道，我为那感到自豪。以及我们和他们之间的鸿沟。你想要一本能告诉你，
like, how do we solve tribalism? How do we deal, like, directly with intergroup conflict? And if I had an answer in that book, it was more like, don't trust your emotions quite as much, be a deep pragmatist, but that's not like a program, right? So after that book was published, I did some kind of soul searching and sort of think, okay, well, what would it take to really apply what we know
比如，我们如何解决部落主义？我们如何直接处理群体间冲突？如果我在那本书里有一个答案，它更像是，不要太相信你的情绪，做一个深度实用主义者，但这不像是一个程序，对吧？所以在那本书出版后，我进行了一些灵魂拷问，心想，好吧，那么，要真正应用我们所知道的，
or what we think we know more directly? And, you know, I thought, all right, well, I'll take a look at what do we know about intergroup conflict, which has not really been my field, or political polarization, which also not been my field. And I sort of looked at the research, and I, you know, I thought, oh, maybe I'll have some big new theory about intergroup conflict or polarization. And when I looked at the research, I thought, you know, a lot of these old ideas seem to be pretty well supported and make a lot of sense. So on the biology side, the answer that comes out of like, what does it take to bring people
或者我们认为我们知道的东西，需要什么？而且，你知道，我想，好吧，我会看看我们对群体间冲突了解多少，这并不是我的领域，或者政治极化，也不是我的领域。我查看了研究，我，你知道，我想，哦，也许我会对群体间冲突或极化有一个宏大的新理论。当我查看研究时，我想，你知道，许多这些旧观点似乎得到了很好的支持，而且非常有道理。所以在生物学方面，关于需要什么来把人们
together is mutually beneficial cooperation. That is everything that evolves. All complex living systems are sustained through mutually beneficial cooperation. Molecules come together to form cells, cells form organisms, organisms form societies. That's the heart of everything. And then on the social science side, you've got ideas going back at least to the 50s, like Gordon Alport's contact theory in his landmark book, The Nature of Prejudice. And Sharif and Sharif, the classic Robbers Cave study, All of those things point to the idea that what you need to do is bring people together under what I would describe as circumstances that are conducive to cooperation. And so I thought, huh, so if the social science and the life sciences are all pointing to the
聚集在一起的答案是互利合作。也就是说，所有进化的东西。所有复杂的生命系统都是通过互利合作来维持的。分子聚集在一起形成细胞，细胞形成生物体，生物体形成社会。这是万物的核心。然后在社会科学方面，你有至少可以追溯到50年代的观点，比如戈登·奥尔波特（Gordon Allport）在他里程碑式的著作《偏见的本质》（The Nature of Prejudice）中提出的接触理论。以及谢里夫和谢里夫（Sherif and Sherif）经典的“强盗洞穴”（Robbers Cave）研究，所有这些都指向一个观点，即你需要做的是在某种我称之为有利于合作的环境下把人们聚集在一起。所以我心想，哈，所以如果社会科学和生命科学都指向
same direction that basically what you need to do to bring people together is mutually beneficial cooperation teamwork, like, why have we not solved this already? I mean, these are old ideas. And not only that, they're probably much older than the research we know. I mean, it's pretty intuitive, right? And I came to the conclusion that it was more about engineering than understanding the basic principles, right? And it's not that this doesn't work. I mean, there are historical cases where the circumstances are right and people come together across lines of division and work together and that really forms a bond, right? And we see this, you know, classic historical examples in the U.S. are the integration of the U.S. military. People thought black people and white people would never be able to fight together in the military. And it worked beautifully.
同一个方向，即基本上你需要做的是互利合作、团队合作来把人们聚集在一起，为什么我们还没有解决这个问题？我的意思是，这些都是旧观点。不仅如此，它们可能比我们知道的研究要古老得多。我的意思是，这很直观，对吧？我得出的结论是，这更多是关于工程学，而不是理解基本原则，对吧？并不是说这不起作用。我的意思是，有历史案例表明，当环境合适时，人们会跨越分歧界限走到一起并共同努力，这确实形成了纽带，对吧？我们看到这一点，你知道，美国经典的例子是美国军队的种族融合。人们认为黑人和白人永远无法在军队中并肩作战。但它运作得非常完美。
and the military, you know, for all of its flaws, became one of the most successfully integrated, you know, institutions in American life and in the world. Sports is another example that people often bring up in for good reason. And those are cases where there's a war to be one. There are games to be won in baseball, right? And you just want the best players. And when people work together,
而且军队，你知道，尽管它有种种缺陷，却成为了美国乃至世界上最成功融合的机构之一。体育是人们经常提到的另一个例子，而且理由充分。这些都是有战争要赢的情况。棒球比赛中有比赛要赢，对吧？你只需要最好的球员。当人们共同努力时，
it's really hard to dislike the people who you depend on to win, whether that's saving your life and saving your country or winning the ballgame. And really, every modern city is a testament to the idea that people of different races and backgrounds and ethnicities can view each other more as cooperation partners than as dangerous enemies, right? So we know this can happen through history's sort of fortuitous circumstances,
很难不喜欢那些你依赖他们来获胜的人，无论是拯救你的生命和国家，还是赢得球赛。事实上，每一座现代城市都证明了这样一个观点：不同种族、背景和民族的人们可以更多地将彼此视为合作伙伴，而不是危险的敌人，对吧？所以我们知道这可以通过历史的偶然情况发生，
but what we don't know is how do you engineer this wherever you are? And so my thinking was, well, how do we get people on the same team and how do we do it in a way that is scalable so you can really make a dent in the problem, right? So a lot of when people address things like intergroup conflict and climate change, people's first thought is dialogue. Bring people together, have them talk it out, right? And all part, you know,
但我们不知道的是，无论你在哪里，如何设计这种合作？所以我的想法是，好吧，我们如何让人们在同一个团队中，以及我们如何以一种可扩展的方式做到这一点，这样你才能真正对这个问题产生影响，对吧？所以当人们解决群体间冲突和气候变化等问题时，很多人的第一反应是对话。把人们聚集在一起，让他们谈出来，对吧？而且奥尔波特，你知道，
paid attention to these kinds of things. And there are wonderful programs like Seeds of Peace, which is going on for decades in Israel, which brings Arab slash Palestinian youth and Jewish Israeli youth together to a summer camp in Maine. And they may come in skeptical and they come away best friends who are crying at the end of the summer. And it really works beautifully. But the seed metaphor has a problem, which is the idea is that these people are going to go out and be the seeds. And what happens is it's not that those people don't go out and do good. And it's not, you know, we don't have a controlled experiment here, but I assume that the world would be even, we'd be even worse shape if it weren't for all the people who've been through programs like seeds of peace. But it hasn't solved the problem, right?
关注过这类事情。而且有一些很棒的项目，比如“和平之种”（Seeds of Peace），它在以色列已经进行了几十年，它把阿拉伯/巴勒斯坦青年和犹太以色列青年带到缅因州的一个夏令营。他们来的时候可能持怀疑态度，但离开时却成了在夏天结束时哭泣的最好的朋友。它确实运作得非常完美。但种子隐喻有一个问题，那就是这个想法是这些人会出去成为种子。而发生的情况是，并不是那些人没有出去做好事。而且，你知道，我们这里没有对照实验，但我假设如果不是因为所有参加过像“和平之种”这样项目的人，世界会变得更糟。但它并没有解决问题，对吧？
And one way to think about this is during the pandemic, we learned about the concept of are not. This is the sort of coefficient that describes whether or not the virus spreads. And basically, if R not is greater than one, if it's 1.2, then for every person who gets the thing, 1.2 people get it as a result, and the thing goes viral. And if R0 is 0.9, then for everyone who gets it, fewer people get it in the next round and it's going to, and it dies out. And I think what happens with programs like seeds of pieces, it's not that they don't have positive spillover effects, but they don't go viral, right? They don't grow from seeds to forest. So you need something that's more inherently scalable. And then there's also a self-selection problem that the people who would
思考这个问题的一种方法是在大流行期间，我们了解了R0的概念。这是描述病毒是否传播的系数。基本上，如果R0大于1，如果是1.2，那么对于每一个感染该病毒的人，结果会有1.2个人感染，事情就会像病毒一样传播。如果R0是0.9，那么对于每一个感染的人，下一轮感染的人数会更少，它就会消失。我认为像“和平之种”这样的项目发生的情况是，并不是它们没有积极的溢出效应，而是它们不会像病毒一样传播，对吧？它们不会从种子长成森林。所以你需要一些本质上更可扩展的东西。而且还有一个自我选择问题，即那些会
come into a program like Seeds of Peace in Israel or dialogue groups like in the U.S., like groups like Braver Angels that bring people together across the red, blue, divide, to talk. Those are the people who are willing to devote their time to cross-partisan dialogue. If everyone were like them, we probably would not be in the situation that we're in, right? So you have this self-selection problem, and you have this scale problem, right? And so what we wanted is, well, how do you take the core principle behind a lot of these things, that is bringing people together in a cooperative context, dial it up so that you're not just being cooperative,
参加像以色列的“和平之种”或美国对话小组（如“勇敢天使”（Braver Angels），将人们聚集在一起跨越红蓝分歧进行交谈）这样项目的人。那些是愿意投入时间进行跨党派对话的人。如果每个人都像他们一样，我们可能就不会处于我们现在的境地，对吧？所以你有这个自我选择问题，你有这个规模问题，对吧？所以我们想要的是，好吧，你如何采取这些事情背后的核心原则，即在合作背景下把人们聚集在一起，调高它，这样你不仅是在合作，
but actually have a mutually beneficial cooperative task, put people on the same team to win something, make it so that it can spread and make it so that it's enjoyable so that it's fun so that it's not just the bleeding heart bridgers who are there trying to talk to each other, but regular people. So our solution to this,
而且实际上有一个互利合作的任务，让人们在同一个团队中去赢得某些东西，使它能够传播，并使它变得令人愉快，这样它就很有趣，这样它就不只是那些心地善良的桥梁建设者在那里试图互相交谈，而是普通人。所以我们对此的解决方案，
and this was where originally started with grad student, M.D. Philippus, now led by the amazing Lucas Woodley, we had people play this game, which we now call Tango. So it is a cooperative quiz game where you play with a partner, and ideally a partner from across the political divide if we're doing this in the U.S.
这是最初与研究生M.D. Philippus开始的，现在由了不起的Lucas Woodley领导，我们让人们玩这个游戏，我们现在称之为“探戈”（Tango）。所以它是一个合作问答游戏，你和搭档一起玩，如果我们是在美国做这个，理想情况下是一个来自政治分歧另一方的搭档。
So you log out of the game, you answer some questions about yourself. Some of them are kind of, you know, about your politics, liberal, conservative, how much, how little. And some of them are kind of fun facts, like, you know, what are fun things about yourself, like, you know, what kind of superpower
所以你登录游戏，回答一些关于你自己的问题。其中一些是关于你的政治倾向，自由派、保守派，程度如何。还有一些是关于有趣的事实，比如，你知道，关于你自己的有趣事情，比如，你最想拥有什么样的超级能力
would you most want to have and things like that? You get to know the other person. You come up with a team name together, and then you get into the quiz. And the quiz, I'll talk about the U.S. political version, is designed to have a sort of complimentary knowledge. So Republicans are more likely to know about the show Duck Dynasty. This is not just stereotypes. This is empirically validated. Republicans are more likely to know about that show, whereas Democrats are more likely to know about stranger things or the Queen's Gambit.
等等？你开始了解对方。你们一起想出一个队名，然后进入问答环节。而问答环节，我会谈谈美国政治版本，旨在拥有某种互补的知识。所以共和党人更有可能了解《鸭子王朝》（Duck Dynasty）这部剧。这不仅仅是刻板印象。这是经过实证验证的。共和党人更有可能了解那个节目，而民主党人更有可能了解《怪奇物语》（Stranger Things）或《后翼弃兵》（The Queen's Gambit）。
Yeah. Yeah. Your laughs are giving you away. I know. Oh, I know. Right. And so, you know, you have that like that. And so people, I know this, you know that. We work together. High five. This is fun.
是的。是的。你们的笑声出卖了你们。我知道。哦，我知道。对吧。所以，你知道，你有那个，那个。所以人们，我知道这个，你知道那个。我们一起努力。击掌。这很有趣。
And, you know, winning points, winning money. And then later in the game, we get into more political stuff. So what percentage of gun deaths in the U.S. involve assault weapons. If you ask liberals, they'll often say something like 30%, 40%. As conservatives, they'll say, no, it's like three or four percent. And in this case, the conservatives are right. That actually assault weapons count for relatively few gun deaths, not that they're not terrible, but it's mostly handguns. But if you ask about rates of crime among immigrants,
而且，你知道，赢得积分，赢得金钱。然后在游戏后期，我们进入更多政治性的东西。所以美国枪支死亡中，攻击性武器占百分之几。如果你问自由派，他们通常会说30%、40%左右。作为保守派，他们会说，不，大概是3%或4%。在这种情况下，保守派是对的。实际上，攻击性武器导致的枪支死亡相对较少，并不是说它们不糟糕，但主要是手枪。但如果你问移民中的犯罪率，
conservatives are much more likely to think that it's sky high, whereas liberals will say correctly that actually immigrants commit relatively few crimes and in fact have a lower rate of crime than the native-born U.S. citizens. So you have questions like this where sometimes the liberal hunch is right and sometimes the conservative hunch is right. And what we find is that when people play with someone who's different from them, they're respectful and they work it out and they listen to each other. Sometimes I'm right and sometimes you're right and sometimes we're both wrong and sometimes we're both right. And we have this positive cooperative experience where, you know, we played together. It was fun. We learned some interesting things. We had our assumptions
保守派更有可能认为它高得离谱，而自由派会正确地说，实际上移民犯下的罪行相对较少，事实上犯罪率比美国本土出生的公民还要低。所以你有这样的问题，有时自由派的直觉是对的，有时保守派的直觉是对的。我们发现，当人们与与自己不同的人一起玩时，他们是尊重的，他们解决了问题，他们倾听对方。有时我是对的，有时你是对的，有时我们都错了，有时我们都对了。我们有这种积极的合作体验，你知道，我们一起玩了。这很有趣。我们学到了一些有趣的事情。我们有我们的假设
challenged in ways that are interesting. And it works. And when I say that it works, what I mean is we measure before and after how warm or cold do you feel towards Republicans or towards Democrats. How would you divide $100 between a random Republican and a random Democrat? How much do you respect Democrats? How much you trust Democrats? Same with Republicans. And we find out all these measures, people play the game with someone who's politically different from them. We see big immediate effects on this. So when it comes to like the feeling
以有趣的方式受到挑战。而且它奏效了。当我说是奏效时，我的意思是我们在前后测量你对共和党人或民主党人的感觉有多热或多冷。你会如何在随机的共和党人和随机的民主党人之间分配100美元？你有多尊重民主党人？你有多信任民主党人？共和党人也一样。我们发现所有这些指标，人们与在政治上与他们不同的人玩游戏。我们看到这对这有很大的直接影响。所以当涉及到像感觉
thermometer, it's the equivalent of rolling, it's like nine degrees. It's like the equivalent of rolling back 15 years of increased animosity in the United States. And then, of course, It's not magic. It fades over time, but we still can detect effects four months later from playing the game once. The results I just described were just published in our paper. It was in Nature, Human Behavior. It came out this summer.
温度计，这相当于回滚，就像九度。这就像回滚了美国15年加剧的敌意。当然，这不是魔法。它会随着时间推移而减弱，但我们仍然可以在玩过一次游戏四个月后检测到效果。我刚才描述的结果刚刚发表在我们的论文中。它发表在《自然-人类行为》（Nature Human Behavior）上。它是今年夏天出来的。
So that's, again, Lucas Woodley's the lead author on that. And that describes five randomized control trials replicating our finding that these positive effects last up to four months. It could be even longer. We haven't gone out that far. And critically, the modal enjoyment rating, I think even the median enjoyment rating across our experiments, is 10 out of 10. Now, these are people doing research studies, so they're not really expecting to have a great time. So this is, you know, low expectations are working to our advantage here, but people do really enjoy the game. And we get great comments from people saying, wow,
所以，再次强调，Lucas Woodley是主要作者。这描述了五个随机对照试验，复制了我们的发现，即这些积极影响持续长达四个月。甚至可能更长。我们还没有走那么远。而且至关重要的是，我认为即使是我们在实验中的中位数享受评分，也是10分满分。现在，这些人是在做研究，所以他们并没有真正期望玩得很开心。所以这是，你知道，低期望值在这里对我们有利，但人们确实非常喜欢这个游戏。我们从人们那里得到了很棒的评论，说，哇，
this is so much fun if you're ever doing this again, et cetera, sir. So, okay, so that, you know, we spent years getting those RCTs done. And then for the last year or two, we've been working on getting this out in the field. We've been starting on college campuses. You know, used to be college campuses where you go to get convenience subject, you know, participants. But now college campuses, as you know, are like ground zero for political polarization and challenge, not just about right-left politics, but things like Israel, Gaza, et cetera. So we've been developing tango games that work for the right-left divide on college campuses, but also things that divide people along different axes related to things like the war in the Middle East. And we've been
这太有趣了，如果你再做这个，等等，先生。所以，好吧，所以那个，你知道，我们花了几年时间完成了那些随机对照试验。然后过去一两年，我们一直致力于将其应用到实地。我们已经开始在大学校园里做了。你知道，过去大学校园是你去获取便利受试者的地方。但现在大学校园，如你所知，是政治极化和挑战的震中，不仅是关于左右政治，还有像以色列、加沙等问题。所以我们一直在开发适合大学校园左右分歧的探戈游戏，但也包括那些沿着与中东战争等相关轴线划分人们的东西。而且我们一直在
doing pilot studies with us now at several schools. But most recently, we did tango games with the entire incoming class at Harvard. So the class of 2029, over a thousand students, and we see positive effects on all of our outcome measures. So the one I'm most proud of, or the combination I'm most proud of, you may have heard of this in the news, Harvard does lean liberal. So, you know, about 80% of students identify as some kind of liberal, but about 20% do identify as some kind of conservative. And what we found is that when liberals played with the conservatives at Harvard, the liberals showed a seven-point increase in their feeling of less cold and more warm towards conservative students. And the conservative said that they had a five-point increase in the extent to which they said they felt comfortable voicing controversial opinions at Harvard.
现在在几所学校进行试点研究。但最近，我们与哈佛大学的整个新生班级进行了探戈游戏。所以2029届，超过一千名学生，我们在所有的结果指标上都看到了积极的影响。所以我最自豪的一个，或者我最自豪的组合，你可能在新闻中听说过，哈佛确实倾向于自由派。所以，你知道，大约80%的学生认同某种自由派，但大约20%的学生确实认同某种保守派。我们发现，当自由派与哈佛的保守派一起玩时，自由派对保守派学生的感觉从冷淡到温暖，显示出七分的增长。而保守派表示，他们对自己说在哈佛表达有争议观点时感到舒适的程度增加了五分。
Which is really important as we try to take seriously, you know, we want this to be a place where people can really speak their minds. And we can, you know, universities have to be places where people can be honest and open about their political beliefs and not feel that they're being silenced. So Tango had a great effect on that with a thousand students. We induced them to play. I mean, they had, there was part of orientation, but we also gave away Red Sox tickets. So we had a group of like 20 top performing teams go to the ball game, which was awesome. We also encourage people to meet up in real life. People often ask us, okay, so it's nice that people report these changes on the survey going out,
这真的很重要，因为我们试图认真对待，你知道，我们希望这是一个人们可以真正畅所欲言的地方。而且我们可以，你知道，大学必须是人们可以诚实和公开地表达他们的政治信仰，而不觉得他们被噤声的地方。所以探戈对一千名学生产生了很好的影响。我们诱导他们去玩。我的意思是，他们有，这是迎新活动的一部分，但我们也赠送了红袜队的门票。所以我们有一组大约20个表现最好的团队去看了球赛，这太棒了。我们也鼓励人们在现实生活中见面。人们经常问我们，好吧，所以人们在调查中报告这些变化很好，
but does they actually do anything? So we have people say, look, if you give your contact information, do you want to meet your partner, if your partner gives their contact information, we'll connect you and suggest, you know, when you can meet at the dining hall. And we had over 10% of the people who played the game meet up with their partners in the dining hall at equal rates, whether their partner was politically similar or different from them. So we're really excited about doing this on college campuses. We also did orientation for Cornell's three business schools this year, and that went great. If you're out there listening and you want to bring this to your school, you can send it to
但他们真的做了什么吗？所以我们让人说，看，如果你提供你的联系信息，你想见你的搭档吗，如果你的搭档提供了他们的联系信息，我们会联系你们并建议，你知道，你们什么时候可以在食堂见面。而且我们有超过10%玩过游戏的人在食堂与他们的搭档见面，无论他们的搭档在政治上与他们相似还是不同，比例都是一样的。所以我们真的很高兴能在大学校园里做这件事。我们今年还为康奈尔大学的三所商学院做了迎新活动，进展非常顺利。如果你在听，并且你想把这个带到你的学校，你可以把它发给
me, Josh Green, or you can go to let's tango.org and drop a note on our website. We are working to to build this out on college campuses, and ultimately what we want is we want to get this into businesses. And I think that actually this can be something that can not only work for the sort of problem of political polarization and animosity, but employee engagement. You know, we've got remote workers
我，Josh Green，或者你可以去letstango.org并在我们的网站上留言。我们正在努力在大学校园里建立这个，最终我们想要的是我们想把它带入企业。而且我认为实际上这不仅可以解决政治极化和敌意的问题，还可以解决员工敬业度的问题。你知道，我们有远程工作者
who feel a little disconnected from their jobs. If you play this game with people who are fellow employees, and there's a real business case for this, and then we're working on building an online version of this, the challenge there is we need people on at the same time. And until you have really high-volve, people are only going to wait a few seconds for a partner. So we're working on building an AI partner that's trained on our thousands of chat transcripts of real Republicans, Democrats,
他们觉得与工作有点脱节。如果你和身为员工的同事玩这个游戏，这确实有一个真正的商业案例，而且我们正在努力建立这个游戏的在线版本。那里的挑战是我们同时需要人在线。而且在你拥有非常高的流量之前，人们只会等待搭档几秒钟。所以我们正在努力建立一个人工智能搭档，它是在我们数千份真实的共和党人、民主党人、
liberals, conservatives playing these games. So you can come on and play the game with the voice of a thousand Democrats or the voice of a thousand Republicans. And then while you're playing with the bot, maybe a human will come along and you'll be able to play with a real human or you can sign up for a game with a real human. So that's down the road. Our goal is to have millions of people have this positive cooperative experience with people who are different from them. We want to take the idea behind a program like Seeds of Peace and Braver Angels,
自由派、保守派玩这些游戏的聊天记录上训练的。所以你可以上来，用一千个民主党人的声音或一千个共和党人的声音玩这个游戏。然后当你和机器人玩的时候，也许会有一个人类出现，你将能够和一个真正的人类一起玩，或者你可以注册一个与真正人类一起玩的游戏。所以那还在未来。我们的目标是让数百万人与与他们不同的人有这种积极的合作体验。我们想采取像“和平之种”和“勇敢天使”这样的项目背后的想法，
but do something where we can reach millions of people. We've got the evidence that it really opens people up and shifts people's attitudes that increases trust and respect. And I should say, it doesn't try to change people's minds, right? Like this is something important. People sometimes think, well, I don't want you to brainwash me and try to convince me that my views are wrong.
但做一些我们可以触及数百万人事情。我们有证据表明它确实让人们敞开心扉并改变了人们的态度，增加了信任和尊重。我应该说，它并不试图改变人们的想法，对吧？这很重要。人们有时会想，好吧，我不想让你给我洗脑，试图说服我我的观点是错的。
That's not what this is about. I think it's healthy in a different. democracy for people to disagree. We're not telling people that they shouldn't disagree. But the only we're going to make those disagreements productive is if there's a baseline level of respect and trust if we can see the humanity in the people who we disagree with. And that, I think, is our big problem right now. So we are working to get tango out there. And if you're interested in playing or having your organization, your school play, or giving us lots of money to help us scale this up, please get in touch. Dr. Green, this has been a lot of fun. And this is really great.
这不是这个游戏的初衷。我认为在一个民主国家，人们有分歧是健康的。我们并不是告诉人们他们不应该有分歧。但我们让这些分歧变得富有成效的唯一方法是，如果有一种基本的尊重和信任，如果我们能看到我们有分歧的人身上的人性。而那，我认为，是我们现在面临的大问题。所以我们正在努力把探戈推广出去。如果你有兴趣玩，或者让你的组织、你的学校玩，或者给我们很多钱来帮助我们扩大规模，请联系我们。格林博士，这非常有趣。而且这真的很棒。
stuff that you're doing. I really appreciate your taking the time to talk to us today. This was great. Thank you so much. I really appreciate you're giving the opportunity. We're super excited about tango and about give directly.org slash speak for our pods fight property campaign. And I just want to tell our listeners that you can find previous episodes of speaking of psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, you can subscribe and leave a a review. And again, if you want to contribute to the Pods Fight Poverty campaign, you can do so by going to give directly.org backslash speak. That's give directly.org backslash speak. And your donation
你正在做的事情。我非常感谢你今天抽出时间与我们交谈。这太棒了。非常感谢。我非常感谢你给我这个机会。我们对探戈和givedirectly.org/speak为我们的“豆荚对抗贫困”（Pods Fight Poverty）运动感到非常兴奋。我只想告诉我们的听众，你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org上，或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方找到“心理学谈话”之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，你可以订阅并留下评论。再次强调，如果你想为“豆荚对抗贫困”运动做出贡献，你可以通过访问givedirectly.org/speak来做到这一点。那是givedirectly.org/speak。你的捐款
will be matched one and a half times. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening. American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. You can't reason with the sun. Trust us. We've tried. This summer, it's time to put that angry ball of fire on mute.
将被匹配一点五倍。如果你对未来的剧集有评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们speakingofpsychology@apa.org。“心理学谈话”由Lee Winerman制作。感谢您的收听。美国心理学会。我是Kim Mills。你无法与太阳讲道理。相信我们。我们试过了。这个夏天，是时候让那个愤怒的火球静音了。
Columbia's Omnishade technology is engineered to protect you from the sun's harsh rays that can burn and damage your skin. The sun is relentless, but so is our gear. Level up your summer at Columbia.com to spend more time outside and less time slathering on allotion. You're welcome. Columbia. engineered for whatever There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哥伦比亚（Columbia）的Omnishade技术旨在保护你免受太阳刺眼光线的伤害，这些光线会灼伤并损害你的皮肤。太阳是无情的，但我们的装备也是。在Columbia.com升级你的夏天，花更多时间在户外，少花时间涂抹乳液。不客气。哥伦比亚。为任何情况而设计。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。